we're gonna review a Kingsman you got
address at like a king's Mitch funny
because I'm in America that would make
me one of those statesmen if anything
and they don't dress like whatever let's
review
[Music]
Kingsman a Golden Circle
so Kings win the Golden Circle is the
sequel to Kingsman the Secret Service by
Matthew Vaughn Matthew Vaughn returns to
direct this one and in Kings win the
Golden Circle we have a new batty played
by Julianne Moore who doesn't attack on
the Kingsmen base you saw in the trailer
their headquarters gone so now the
remaining Kingsman Merlin and eggsy need
to team up with the Statesmen in the
United States which is American Kings
man but with a lot more whiskey and they
need to take out the new batting and at
this point tarron Edgerton has it down
man dude is really good he was great in
the first Kingsman movie he's great in
this movie didn't franchise that's
ultimately supposed to be a more
exaggerated version of James Bond for
the 21st century he's a great James Bond
what I really liked in this movie were
the Statesmen I was really worried
Kingsman the Secret Service I really
love this style I love the suits
I love the methodology I love the rules
I loved everything about the Kingsmen so
incorporating a new organization from
another country I was like that's either
gonna mix or I'm gonna leave the theater
to my surprise it really mixed they had
their own style their own flash new
weapons and a couple of the throw down
shootouts when one of them is spinning
the revolver on his finger and it's just
shoot shoot shoot shoot shoot and not
deny the style and I love that the
weapons and the text are very specific
for the organization's the statesmen
don't use what the Kingsmen would use
the Kingsmen don't use but the statesmen
would use could you see a Kingsman
rocking an electric lasso I could not
over the Statesmen totally work however
this movie does fall under a little bit
of a sequel I this blanket and that is
the mindset of okay what we had in the
first movie worked in the first movie so
now we're gonna have that but just much
more of it here but you know in that
church shootout in Kingsman the Secret
Service how the camera was doing that
weird zoom and pan around thing I don't
know that's not the only scene in the
first movie that used it but it's a
scene that completely illustrates that
I'm trying to say this movie has so many
scenes that use that weird jarring
camera zoom pan around thing that it
almost looks unnatural and pulls you out
of it granted these shootouts and action
sequences are entertaining but if I had
a gripe about them that'd be it and in
the world where something like this
happens to the king's men's home base is
gonna be a death or two that makes me go
why did you have to kill that person
that just bothered me Colin Firth does
make a
in this movie in for a long time I was
like did we have to have him in here
straight up his storyline totally
paralyzed there's a men in black 2 thing
happening here but at a point in the
movie Colin Firth totally justifies his
presence here doesn't change the fact
that proceeding that there was this
whole block of time er I was like why is
he here other than the fact that it's a
sequel and you kind of have to have him
in it I guess and in a world of making
everything more for a sequel I feel like
the first movie was a throwback to James
Bond this movie has such exaggerated
gadgets such exaggerated tech it
actually breaches in a comic book
territory which I'm completely fine with
but it doesn't change the fact that this
feels more like a comic book movie
where's the 1st Kingsman movie felt like
an interesting take on the old-school
James Bond world is in the end Kingsman
the Golden Circle was a lot of fun it's
not as clean as the first movies not as
pure as the first movie but it was still
a lot of fun and there's this Throwdown
in a bar exciting as hell I love the
music that played to it I will say
Kingsman the Golden Circle is a fun time
no alcohol acquired alright guys so
Kingsman the Golden Circle have you seen
it what did you think about it what's
your favorite spy movie eccentric or
otherwise whatever it is whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]